welcome back Miracle flights provides
free air transportation to children and
adults who need help reaching special
Medical Care and they do this year round
but they have some extra special
initiatives going on throughout the
holiday so here to tell us more we have
Linda Bridges from Miracle flights
alongside sisters Rebecca and Amanda who
have taken several Miracle flights thank
you all so much for being here Linda
I'll start with you tell us a little bit
more about Miracle flights you guys do
some really really great work we do so
Miracle flights has been around since
1985. and we provide about 600 flights
per month to families like Amanda's
family who need Specialized Care in
cities that may not you know be there
close to home city so we get them to
that City for their medical care and
Rebecca I'll bring you into the
conversation you're speaking on behalf
of your sister Amanda and your family
what's it been like to have the support
of Miracle flights and providing that
that care for your sister well with
Miracle flights my sister is able to get
medical treatment at Stanford at Lucille
Packard's Children Hospital Capital
where they do have an epileptologist for
her rare form of epilepsy which we
wouldn't have been able to get in Nevada
so now it's just easier to fly over to
California with the help of Miracle
flights well this is just proof of one
of the many families that you help
support and that we can all help support
in the community so let's talk about the
holidays you have some special things
going on especially at downtown
Summerlin I love seeing all the lit up
signs tell us about those we sure do so
right now through December 31st at
downtown Summerlin we have our lights
for flights campaign powered by solup so
when you're shopping at Downtown
Summerlin you'll see those signs there's
six big illuminated words that really
embody the holidays they embody Miracle
flights they say joy and miracle and
love when you're shopping snap that
selfie snap a photo and donate to
Miracle flights yeah you can't miss them
when you're walking through the mall and
this is the second year that you're
doing it so now we're really amping up
the importance of it and how great is it
to have the support of downtown
Summerlin and the community uni kind of
backing you for miracle flights oh
absolutely so we need the support of all
of our community Downtown Summerlin
Seoul up to really support our families
to get them to the medical care they
need absolutely absolutely and Rebecca
For You especially during the holidays
is that great for your family to get to
walk through and see these signs and
just kind of be reminded of everything
Miracle flights has done for you guys oh
yeah definitely
um when we went to see the signs the
other day we did see Amanda sign up and
it was just a reminder of how much
Miracle flights has been there for our
family well Rebecca Amanda to your
family thank you so much for being here
and sharing your story and we're wishing
you nothing but the best care and Linda
thank you for everything you guys do
with Miracle flight so be sure to go to
downtown Summerlin and thank you to
Miracle flights for sponsoring this
segment you can call
800-359-1711 or visit miracleflights.org
or you can also scan that QR code right
there on your screen for more
information we will be right back